le chiffre est plutôt étonnant dans une
société où les enfants semblent roi 87 %
des parents reconnaissent donner de
temps en temps une fessée le martinet en
revanche est en totale perte de vitesse
et c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça ce qui
est sûr c'est que les français veulent
rester maîtres chez eux et qu'il
n'envisage pas une seconde que l'état
puisse institué une loi sur la question
anne guéri diane richard
un beau geste ample assumer énergique
c'est la fusée façon début de siècle ce
qu'on appelait encore il n'ya pas si
longtemps une bonne rouste en loin
d'être démodé la fessée gare toutes ses
vertus pour beaucoup 87 % des parents
interrogés avouent avoir donné une
fessée 62% 10 après coup qu'elle était
mérité la nuance c'est que les pères
assume à 82% les maires culpabiliser à
53%
alors pour ou contre quiconque c'est le
single little dans ce sens de leurs un
enfant il faut qu'il sache le bien et le
mal
quand c'est bien mon décès des bisous on
sait pas bien c'est les petites fessées
reprend de l'autre me voilà j'expliquais
gironde et que sa marge se souvient que
la sauce et mieux qu'elle a pu faire la
fessée est interdite dans 11 pays
européens la suède en tête mais la
france fait de la résistance
malgré ça si tu manges pas tu vas t'en
prendre une ans qu'il trop gentil avec
elle écoute
laisse moi faire qu'il en fait qu'à une
campagne lancée en 2003 contre la fessée
et on peut le dire sans succès 95 % du
panel dit avoir eu une fessée dans ces
conditions il n'y a guère que les psys
pour la condamner il ya quelque chose de
paradoxal à dire puisque été un ratage
images deviennent fait c'est parce qu'à
ce moment-là donner une fessée c'est
agir mal cette maltraitance dans ce que
l'enfant retiens c'est plutôt la
maltraitance que le que le côté
correctifs 64 % des enfants qui ont subi
la fessée disent qu'à leur tour ils en
donneront faut-il y voir une raison de
désespérer bien en rester là
quoi qu'il en soit tant que le sondage
fera loi
la fille c'est aura un bel avenir